hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the knockouts
phase of the
magnus carlson invitational it's a game
from the quarterfinals yanni palmisha
versus hikaru nakamura and hikaru won
the first game very nicely and now uh
nepo needs to bonds back to get back
into the match and as the title suggests
this is exactly what happens and it's
it's quite quite a nice one so i'm sure
you're gonna enjoy it it's
very very short uh but you know uh with
with a lot of depth
so without further ado let's check it
out nipple with the white pieces opens
with e4
sorry about that uh we have knight the
uh
we have e5 by hikaru knight to f3 we
have knight to c6 and bishop to b5 nepal
goes for the rule opus
probably expecting the berlin defense
because hikaru is already up
a point in the match so it makes sense
to play something very solid and
what is more solid than the berlin
defense or or so we think
so uh knight to f6 and now uh nipple
castle so we have knight captures on e4
going for the real gambit and now d4
uh striking in the center this has been
played a million times so we have knight
to d6
and bishop characters removing the
defender of the e5 pawn
the captures and finally pawn captures
on e5 getting rid of the knight and
getting ready to trade queens with uh
knights to f5 and here just queen
captures on the e8 with
czech king captures and knights the c3
and although it seems like a lot of
moves were played
all of them know this uh like you know
if you walk them up in the middle of the
night and ask them you know to instantly
tell you all the moves they would of
course do it because uh there are over 2
000 games in the database with this
exact same position
and it's you know constantly being
played because it is just very solid for
black and black
plays it very more than happily so here
king the e8 this is the main reply
adding another defender to the f7
f7 pawn and not you won't have to worry
about ideas like knight g5 going after
f7
you're ready to develop the light square
bishop and bring the rook into the game
and later on you're going to play moves
like c5 and so on
so here h3 by white and now bishop to e6
he carl continues developing we have g4
pushing back the knight the knight must
go to e7 if you go to h6 you're never
getting it back into the game probably
so knights the e7
and knight to d for now putting pressure
on the bishop
and hikaru of course doesn't want to
allow knight captures bishop he still
has the bishop
parent he's hoping to use it um at some
point he wants to kick away this knight
with c5 maybe put the bishop on c6
control this nice diagonal
uh and you know all the good stuff we
have f4
by nipple now creating a very nice pawn
chain on the king side and now
h5 when someone has a nice pawn chain
it's always uh well
a good idea to undermine it so here h4
preparing h captures an
h5 preparing h captures on g4 and we
have f5 by nippo
uh h captures on g4 and now not
recapturing with h captures on g4 as
this position has been reached uh quite
a few times and uh h captures on g4 is
the move that was always played here
but here nipple goes for e6 and it is
only as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game
now posing some problems for hikarian
hikaru played a
bishop back to c8 or rather he should
have played this he played a pawn
captures on e6
it looks very counter intuitive but it's
very solid bishop to c8
is the correct way to play this and if
you don't play this move
uh you are going to run into problems
because here
yeah although it looks scary you don't
really gain anything for example
captures captures and black is perfectly
fine there if h captures on g4 then you
go after the weak pawn rook to h4
and it's a it's a perfectly safe
position to play for black of course
if you know what you're doing so here
after e6 uh we have
f captures on e6 by hikaru instead we
have f captures on e6 now attacking the
bishop and bishop to c8 but now
uh it's a little bit different because
now the f file is open for the white
rook so
so first bishop to g5 uh so what do you
play here uh we have g
captures on h3 creating a wonderful pass
pawn here and yep
blocks it he doesn't want to allow uh
this pawn to come to h2 with
check then uh this uh well bishop comes
alive as the diagonal will open up
a bit more and for example if check if
the king has to go to the light square
diagonal then c5 and maybe you can
play some like b6 get the bishop over
here so it
definitely makes sense to stop this pawn
on h3 so king h2
and now comes knight the g6 uh
getting the knight back into the game
and now knight the e4 and you can see
how
uh the black king doesn't really have
all that many squares all of these
squares are covered by the pawn
and by the bishop and if uh if the king
only
is you know finds himself in check just
a little bit
that means that it will be checkmate so
here while you could go for rook
uh for example sounds like a bishop to
b6 check it it looks very ugly
uh but it's uh kind of kind of the way
to go here if
white captures then you can capture rook
to f7
and again it's just a very ugly position
to play but it seems black doesn't have
anything better than this
hikaru of course wanted something better
you don't want to you know
suffer like this so instead he played
rook to h5 now he's kind of paralyzing
this knight as the bishop
will will be in trouble
and now comes rook to g1 by nepal if you
try rook to f7 now with some similar
ideas it
doesn't work because now the bishop can
actually capture here uh you haven't
still developed your
dark square bishop so rook captures and
g7 is not an option
and if you go rook captures on c7 then
bishop to d5 is perfectly fine you just
get the bishop out of harms away
and even if rook to e1 getting this rook
here it's still not a problem for black
just knight to e5
and although it looks very scary black
is actually winning here
you can't really move this knight to
open up this uh
this e file because rook captures on g5
uh and then the rook is immediately
guarding the knight so
black will have definitely have plenty
of time to consolidate and win this
position
so instead after rook to h5 we have rook
to g5 adding another defender here
and now uh a6 here's his hikaru wanted
to play c5 but he wanted to avoid knight
to b5 going after c7 and it's uh
it's a very uh difficult position to
face so here he carl played uh
a6 instead now taking away the b5 square
from this knight
and you want to chase it away with c5
but
a6 does not work here here nipple
brought
the rook into the game we have rook to
d1 and he carl of course a master of
puzzle rush
spots that this rook is eyeing that d8
square you don't want to fall for such a
checkmate
so he immediately blocks the diagonal we
have knight to e7
now blocking this bishop but now rook
after
uh uh and now rook d to f1 bringing the
rook back to this diagonal this rook
remains here to guard the bishop but the
disrupt is now very powerful you can
lift it to f7 if you want
uh and here hikaru said uh all right
well
i don't really have a good active move
here all of my pieces are tied down
let's get rid of this knight and then
we're gonna continue developing as i
have now taken away the
uh the b5 square from uh nipples knight
but now
the game is completely winning for uh
for a nippon issue so feel free to pause
the video here and win the game for
nipple
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
bishop capture sun e7 or
the even stronger and faster rook
capture santa fe rook capture sun f8 is
the correct way to go this is what nepal
played and it was in this position on
move 23
uh that hikaru nakamura resigned in the
game and nepo uh
bounces back in the match very nicely so
here you resign because you're in check
and you don't have any move other than
uh
king captures rook uh but after you
capture the rook uh
whatever you play just loses uh after
bishop captures an e7
this is the only move he car didn't even
wait for nipple to play this because he
knew of course nepo calculated all of it
but now nothing works here you can
capture you can move or you can move uh
to g8 but none of it is good if you go
to g8 uh then just
knight to f6 check and that's it uh the
king has nowhere
i mean you have to go to h8 then knight
captures on h5 you lost the rook and
your position is now just terrible
uh on the other hand if you try going
for king
king to d king the e8 then rook captures
on g7 and again
your bishop is defended knight to f6
check is coming and there really isn't
much you can do here uh even better if
you if you capture this
then knight to f6 is checkmate not not
just check because the pawn
uh and the bishop are covering all of
these squares
so what's left after this rook captures
an f8 is the
will capture it and after bishop
captures to actually capture the bishop
but this is not much better now we play
rook captures on g7 with
check king to f8 and now rook to f7
check you could also go for this but
this is a bit more precise so king the
g8 and now
knight to f6 with check uh so what can
you do here only one square for the king
king to h8 and now knight captures an h5
and now you're simply up
up a piece you have a beautiful pass
pawn here and if
black even tries to equalize by
capturing the piece here then just
knight to f6
and there's no defense against the rook
the h7 checkmate
so whatever black plays here it's
checkmate let's say you capture here
then rook the h7 is checkmate and
that's just it uh but he carl of course
calculated all of this he saw after rook
to
rook capture santa fe to check that the
the the game is done
uh and he of course resigned here uh so
yeah
really really a wonderful game i don't
know it i don't i i i don't know if
nipple you know uh reached in his secret
bag of preparations that he's storing
for the candidates tournament and now he
may be wasted
one uh interesting uh idea but i don't
know if um
if this would go for if he would go for
this in a classical game i mean
it doesn't seem like there's anything
wrong with it and if he knows his way
around of course you can play it
uh but i don't i don't know if um maybe
it's uh it's enough to give it a serious
try with the white pieces in such a
serious tournament
uh but yeah uh the the leader of the
candidate bounces back and
we'll see what happens in game three and
for the match is now a tie
uh so uh that's it hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank
locust teocaris dale lear vaseline
velichikov
uh cheese roast and paul hunter for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day